MALE SPEAKER: All right, thank
you all for coming, everybody.
Mr. AO Scott, or Tony, is the
film critic of "The New York
Times" and has been since 2004.
He grew up in
Northampton-- actually,
he was born in
Northampton, Massachusetts.
I'm not sure if he actually grew
up there-- and studied English
and fortunately thought
better of getting a PhD,
and now we have him.
You might have seen him
on TV with Roger Ebert
and in many other venues.
I can say personally,
if I'm looking
to see if I should go
see a movie or not,
I look at two reviews, Tony's
and the Roger Ebert site,
whoever writes that nowadays.
So Tony, have no presentation.
But he'll be glad to
take all your questions
and sign your books.
And if you want to join us for
lunch afterwards, feel free.
One of us is going to
grab a table out there,
assuming it doesn't
start raining.
So without further ado,
please welcome Tony Scott.
[APPLAUSE]
AO SCOTT: Hi.
Thank you all for
coming-- yeah, OK.
I think I'm good-- in the
middle of your work days
when you could be playing
pool or riding bikes
or whatever it is that you do.
But I'm really
glad that you came,
and I'm very excited
to have a chance
to talk about my
new book, "Better
Living Through Criticism-- How
to Think about Art, Pleasure,
Beauty, and Truth."
And one of the main ideas
in this book-- which
is, broadly speaking, about
not so much what critics do,
what professional critics do, as
it is about what criticism is--
is that criticism really
is the conversation
that we have about the things
that are important to us,
about the meaning and the
value and the status of works
of art and products of
the human imagination.
So I would like most of what
happens while we're here
to actually be a conversation.
So I will very shortly
be taking any questions
you have about, really,
anything you want to talk about.
I'm a movie critic.
The Oscar race is happening.
There are things to
be said about that.
There may be reviews
of mine that you've
read that you want to thank
me for, or the opposite.
[LAUGHTER]
Either way, it's all good.
I'm terrible at movie
trivia, so if you
ask me a question about
a particular movie
you will embarrass me.
But you can do that also.
But I do want to
start out by talking
a little bit about the book
and how I came to write it,
and what it's
trying to do and why
I think that the
topic of criticism
is worth talking about
and the idea of criticism
needs defending or
needs articulation.
Now, I started writing-- I
kind of got the idea for this
around 2011 when I was reading
a lot of stuff in newspapers
and magazines and online that
was basically proclaiming
my own imminent
extinction-- that because
of social media, because of
a digital culture, because
of Facebook and
Twitter and Google
and all of these,
and Amazon and Yelp
and these wonderful
algorithms that were coming
into existence-- critics as
they had existed for a very
long time wouldn't
be necessary anymore,
and that for a lot of people it
seemed like a very good thing,
because who needed us
anyway and wasn't nice
that all of those kind
of annoying people
who were spoiling
everyone else's fun
were going to have to
look for real jobs?
And there were other people who
lamented the fact that, well,
now this form of
writing and thinking
and this way of discerning
what is excellent
and what is valuable in
the world of the arts
is going to go
away, and all we're
going to have is just people
hitting the Like button
and civilization will collapse.
[LAUGHTER]
So I was trying to figure out
where I stood on this question.
And as often is the
case, it was kind of
a little more complicated
than the extremes of opinion
would suggest.
But I thought, well, what
is it that critics do?
What is it that I do?
And why might that matter apart
from anyone's particular job
or professional situation?
That is, if there
were no critics,
would there still be criticism?
And I thought, well,
yeah, there would.
Criticism as I understand
it is bigger than and more
important than the particular
jobs of people like me.
So I thought,
well, maybe it'd be
interesting to try to figure
out for myself some good answers
to these questions.
What is criticism?
What are critics for?
Why does any of this matter?
And that very quickly lead
me into much more difficult
and more interesting
questions having
to do with taste,
with art, with how do
we know something is beautiful.
What happens to us
when we experience
a movie or a painting
or a book or a poem,
and we find that
we are moved by it,
or we fail to be moved by it?
How is it that we
can simultaneously
say, well, there's no
disputing taste, right?
Everybody likes something else.
Everybody likes what
they like, and there's
no point in arguing about it.
How do we reconcile
that belief, which
seems very polite and very
tolerant and very civilized,
with the fact that we argue
about it all the time?
When we leave a movie
with our friends,
we don't necessarily just limit
ourselves to saying, well,
I liked that.
It's too bad you didn't.
We say, what do you
mean that was great?
That was terrible.
And we fight about it.
And that fight, that
argument, is a very important
and a very kind of,
I began to think,
deeply central to who we are
as a species, that it lies
very close-- the impulse to
argue, to judge, to evaluate,
to interpret, lies very close to
the impulse to make, to create,
to produce works of
art and representations
of our human experience
in the world.
So I thought, well, if I could
just explain all of that then
that might be an
interesting book.
So I went and I started
doing some research
and trying to figure out
who might have said some
of the things that I would be
trying to say in such a way
that I could get away
with stealing it.
And I found my way, as one does,
to Oscar Wilde, who's really
one of the great critical
spirits in this book--
an amazing writer, a polymath,
a playwright, a poet,
an essayist, a dandy, an
aesthete, a critic, the person
probably with the
best and most perfect
taste in the history
of human beings.
[LAUGHTER]
And I found that he had
written a short book, kind
of almost a pamphlet, called
"The Critic As Artist."
And as some of his essays
are-- the other most famous one
that's like this is called
"The Decay of Lying,"
which is also brilliant
and important in this book.
But "The Critic as
Artist" takes the form
of a dialogue between two
Victorian gentleman of leisure
who spend the
whole night arguing
about the Ancient
Greeks and philosophy
and painting and music.
One of them is named
Gilbert, and he's
kind of the critic figure.
He's the Oscar
Wilde stand-in who
has all of these outrageous
opinions and judgments
and says these shocking
and provocative things.
And the other one, his kind
of straight man or foil,
is Earnest, which is the great
Wildean name for someone who
is perhaps too much in earnest.
So right at the end
of the dialogue in one
of the epigraphs for this
book, Earnest kind of sums up
what they've been talking about.
And he says, "You have
told me many strange things
tonight, Gilbert.
You have told me that it is more
difficult to talk about a thing
than to do it, and that
to do nothing at all
is the most difficult
thing in the world.
You have told me that all art is
immoral, all thought dangerous,
that criticism is more
creative than creation,
and that the highest criticism
is that which reveals
in the work of art what the
artist had not put there,
that is exactly because a man
cannot do a thing that he is
the proper judge of it, and
that the true critic is unfair,
insincere, and not rational."
And I thought, well,
that sounds about right.
So if I could just
prove that, I would have
made a successful argument.
It turned out to be harder
to prove than I thought,
but I did really want to
get into those questions
in that paradoxical spirit
about the relationship
between criticism and art
that didn't just see criticism
as parasitic, as
secondary, as negative,
but actually as making a
central contribution to the way
that we think and
the way that we live.
And Oscar Wilde was very
important in this process.
Another important inspiration
on the way to writing this book
came through Twitter.
It's all right to talk
about-- the other?
Yeah, it's OK?
All right, you're all cool?
You're all friends?
I never know.
Because if you go into
"The New York Times"
and you just start talking about
Buzzfeed or "The Washington
Post," they'll throw you out.
So I'm glad it's more
open-minded here.
But so I wrote a review of an
obscure little movie called
"The Avengers."
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, I don't know.
Some of you might have seen it.
And it was OK.
And I said in the
review it was OK.
There were parts of it that I
liked, and some things about it
that I didn't like.
And I was a little
frustrated at just kind
of some of the
blockbuster cliches
that sort of, I
thought, drowned out
the more entertaining, more
whimsical, more inventive parts
of the movie.
So I guess the day after my
review went up, I went online.
I was looking at
Twitter to see if there
were any cute dogs that
people had taken pictures of.
And I saw my Twitter feed was
full of angry people calling me
all kinds of names.
And I thought, what is going on?
And invoking, as the authority,
the name of Samuel L. Jackson,
Nick Fury himself, Mace Windu,
Jules Winnfield, all these--
[LAUGHTER]
And he had put up a
tweet, although he'd not
treated it at me.
He had just kind of sub-tweeted
me by using my name,
where he said, Avengers fans,
we need to find AO Scott a new
job, one he can--
[LAUGHTER]
--one he can actually do.
And so everyone was like,
yeah, you need a new job.
Yeah, you're an idiot.
Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
And I thought, well,
god, what would that be?
[LAUGHTER]
I don't know.
I think I might have
sent a resume over here.
But nothing came of it.
But it actually got
me thinking after we
had had our fun little Twitter
fight that followed from that
and I wrote something.
I can't even remember
what I tweeted back,
but it must have
been very clever.
Anyway.
[LAUGHTER]
But I thought, well,
what is the job?
How do you actually do it?
And apparently, Samuel L.
Jackson kept thinking about it
also, because six
months later he
did a interview in
"The Huffington Post"
where sort of
unprompted, he came back
to the review nice
and kind of spelled
out everything that was wrong
with the way I was doing
my job-- which was, first of
all, that I was kind of tearing
down what was a perfect film,
a wonderful, great movie that I
just sort of didn't get,
and that also I was wasting
too much time thinking about,
intellectualizing, what was
his word, a piece
of pop culture,
just sort of something
that existed for fun.
And why bring so
much thought, so much
scrutiny, so much
skepticism to it?
And I thought, well, that's
kind of a perfect summary
of the problems that people
have with critics and criticism.
On the one hand, here
is this beautiful thing
that somebody made, whether
it's a movie or a book
or a painting or a poem.
And why do you
want to mess it up?
Why do you want
to knock it down?
to take it apart?
Why can't you just
leave it alone
and let it be the
exquisite thing that it is?
And who the hell are you anyway
to come along and say anything
about it?
And then on the other side, what
happens often when you write
about popular culture is people
say, hey, this is just for fun.
This is like, we want
to go to the movies.
We want to have a good time.
We want to eat some popcorn.
We want to watch some action.
And why do you have
to come in here
and ruin that fun by
either by finding fault
or by over-analyzing?
And I thought those are
very serious challenges,
and they can't be dismissed.
It was, it seemed to me,
worth it to really think
about, what is the relationship
between our pleasures
and our search for
entertainment, for meaning,
for beauty, for whatever
it is that we get out
of works of art, popular
or fine, and the impulse
to think about them,
to analyze them,
to take them apart
and see how they work,
to compare them to each
other, to rank them?
And my answer, in a way, was
that these things go together,
that for me personally, the
thinking about works of art
and what they do and how
they work and enjoying them
are part of the same impulse,
part of the same act.
And my other thought is that
these works of imagination--
whether they're big budget
movies or ancient statues
or paintings or poems or
pieces of popular music
or symphonies-- are
important, are representations
of how we as human
beings are making sense
of our conditions
of life and what
it is to be human
in this very strange
and complicated and
ever-changing world,
and that taking that
seriously is very important
and trivializing it seems
to me a terrible mistake.
So I wanted to
write a book that I
hoped would encourage
people to do that thinking,
to take our own experiences
seriously in a situation where
we're overwhelmed
with competing claims
on our attention of stuff
that we're supposed to like,
to maybe slow down and activate
our minds a little more.
There's one other
thing that I'd like
to read before taking questions
and hearing what you all
have to say.
And it is-- as I was
writing this book,
I kind of did a lot of
reading and research
looking for ideas and for work
in the past that would help
me think about these issues.
And some of it I found in
the history of philosophy
and of criticism.
Some of it I found in Aristotle
and in the work of Pauline Kael
and Susan Sontag and other
contemporary critics.
But I found I often
would discover
some of the most acute
and interesting statements
of the problems that I wanted to
address in works of literature,
in novels and in poems.
And as I was kind
of reading around,
I found a poem by English
poet Philip Larkin,
who was a wonderful mid-century
poet whose best-known
poem is the one called
"This be the Verse," which
begins with the famous
line, "They fuck you up,
your mum and dad.
They may not mean
to, but they do."
You can find the rest
of the poem online.
It's one of the most concise
and depressing statements
of human existence
that's ever been written,
and it's like 12 lines.
And afterwards you're
just like, oh, wow.
[LAUGHTER]
There we go.
The last lines are-- not
to spoil it-- "get out
as quickly as you can, and
don't have any kids yourself."
[LAUGHTER]
So he was a very cheerful guy.
But he was also a
huge jazz fan, and he
wrote a lot of really
terrific jazz criticism.
And he worked most of his
life as a university librarian
in Hull in Northern England.
And he wrote a poem
in the early '50s--
late '40s or early '50s--
called "Reasons for Attendance."
And it was the poem that
for me kind of really
crystallized a lot of what I
wanted to say and to understand
about criticism.
And to set it up a little
bit, the scene of the poem
is the speaker.
This guy who might be Larkin
is walking down the street,
and he passes a dance hall.
He hears music
coming from inside.
He doesn't go inside.
He's kind of looking
through the glass
and seeing the people in
there dancing and listening
to the music and reflecting on
the difference between what's
going on inside, between the fun
that people are having in there
and his own experience of it,
his own reaction to the music
from outside.
So here's the poem.
It's called "Reasons
for Attendance."
"The trumpet's voice,
loud and authoritative,
draws me a moment to the lighted
glass to watch the dancers,
all under 25, shifting intently,
face to flushed face solemnly
on the beat of happiness.
Or so I fancy, sensing
the smoke and the sweat,
the wonderful feel of girls.
Why be out here?
But why then be in there?
Sex, yes.
But what is sex?
Surely to think the
lion's share of happiness
is found by couples--
sheer inaccuracy
as far as I am concerned.
What calls me is that
lifted rough-tongued bell--
art, if you like-- whose
individual sound insists
I too am individual.
It speaks.
I hear.
Others may hear as well, but
not for me nor I for them.
And so with happiness.
Therefore, I stay
outside believing this,
and they mull to and
fro believing that,
and both are satisfied-- if
no one has misjudged himself
or lied."
So that's-- that poem
is a complicated poem.
For me, it kind of
says it says it all
about how our own experience
is sometimes divided
between pleasure and something
else-- reflection, thought,
and how it is that art satisfies
both of those impulses, both
of those desires, and
also leaves us off
in a state of confusion.
And it's in that
confusion, I think,
that criticism can really begin.
But now I'd like to
hear what you have
to say and take your questions.
So yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for that very
thought-provoking introduction.
AO SCOTT: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Many years ago,
when I went to a movie
and I-- talking about
your "Avengers" review--
I started this movie, and I
hated it, absolutely hated it,
when all of a sudden it dawned
on me, this is a comic book.
And then I settled
down and I loved it.
So this preconceived
idea-- I came
in with a preconceived
idea, or maybe no idea.
Just before this
meeting, my daughter
texted me from college
saying she's just read
"The Darling" by Anton Chekhov.
So I quickly looked
up a summary of it
to have a conversation with her.
She yelled at me and said,
don't look up a summary.
You've got to read
the actual book.
So I agreed with her.
But my question is,
what about this idea
that we come to work of art
with preconceived ideas,
with expectations,
with what we've heard--
or do we come to it with
a completely open mind?
I mean, you can't not come
to something without--
AO SCOTT: Right.
But you have to-- it's a
question that comes up a lot.
And it certainly
comes up a lot when
you're a critic,
because you can't
help having preconceptions,
prejudices, being who you are.
I mean, there is no view from
nowhere or view from 50,000
feet-- certainly in criticism,
certainly when you're talking
about works of art and movies
and things that you either
enjoy or you don't.
There's not an objective
measure of these things.
But I think it is possible.
I know it's possible.
It's something that
I try to encourage.
Exactly what you
described-- because it's not
that you get rid of everything
that you believe or everything
you are when you walk in, but
you can also open yourself up.
I think it is possible to let
go of some of those prejudices--
to, just as you described, say,
well, this is something else.
This is not necessarily
what I thought.
But also, in a way, you
can become someone else.
You can put yourself
in the position
that's different from who
you are in everyday life.
I mean, I think
one of the things
that art does that's
so remarkable-- movies
especially-- is provide just
this enormous imaginative
palette that you can
project yourself onto.
So you can sit there
watching a movie.
You can be whoever you want.
You don't have to be the
person in the movie who's
"like you," whatever
that would mean.
No one is stopping you,
nothing is stopping you,
from extending your empathy or
your identification in any way
that you want it to go.
And I think sometimes
people are afraid of that.
And sometimes people
say, well, I like this.
I'm a guy.
I like guy movies.
I don't like girl
movies, or whatever.
Or I just like action movies.
I don't like romance movies.
Or I only like movies
with subtitles,
movies that move really slowly,
where the camera just stares
at one thing for a whole
take and everybody smokes.
[LAUGHTER]
And I love those movies.
But it is possible
and desirable,
and I think in a way, learnable,
to move outside of that.
And one thing that I think--
now in the age of data
that we live in,
we can very easily
be classified and
categorized according
to different algorithms.
So it's like, you like this?
You might also like that.
People who bought
this also bought that.
And you're being kind of
tracked into-- it's like, oh,
I'm a person who likes this.
I'm a person who bought that.
But one of the things that I'm
trying to get at in this book
and saying that kind of a
properly critical spirit can do
is give you a chance to jump
the tracks and go somewhere else
and find something else
which you may not like.
You may come running back
to your comfort zone,
but you had the adventure
and maybe learned something.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So when I think
of criticism, it's
kind of a very personal
matter because I always have
these thoughts on my opinions.
But I was wondering, for someone
whose criticism could, I guess,
be read by millions, is there a
difference in your criticism--
like do you consider
the audience
when you're publishing
versus maybe just when you're
watching something personally?
AO SCOTT: There's less
of a distance, in a way.
I mean, I think
if I thought when
I set down to right about
the audience and about
the institution that
I was writing for,
I think I might
just be paralyzed.
If I thought, oh
my goodness, I have
to write about this for
"The New York Times."
So I think much
more about, well,
how am I going to figure
out what I want to say?
How am I going to work
out my own thoughts?
For me, writing is very much
about clarifying and figuring
out.
I don't really know
what I think until I've
gotten to the end of the
writing process and it's like,
OK, now it kind of
makes sense to me.
So when I sit down to
write, I'm doing that.
I'm thinking about myself.
I'm thinking about maybe a small
group of friends and family
who I want to impress
or shock, and then
the other millions of people or
whoever they are will follow.
I mean, I am aware that
I'm doing it in public
and that I have to do it with
a certain degree of craft
and discipline and that I
only have so many words.
And there are some words
that I'm not allowed to use.
But in general,
as close as I can
get to that own
personal experience--
to turning that
into an argument,
or articulating what happened
to me when I was seeing
that movie in a way
that could make sense
to other people-- the better it
is, the more authentic it is,
the more useful I think it is.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How about
those white Oscars?
[LAUGHTER]
AO SCOTT: Yes, oh my goodness.
Don't even get me started.
Well, you're all
aware of the issue.
And I mean, I think
a lot of people
are going to watch
the show just to see
what happens, to see how
far Chris Rock can go
and whether he will, in a way,
be able to redeem anything.
But I think it's a big problem
not just with the Oscars,
obviously.
I mean, I think that
there is narrowly
a problem with the Academy
that is structural,
that has to do with who is
voting and how they're voting,
and also with how they
think about movies.
The Academy is 6,000 people,
kind of the elite of the movie
business, of Hollywood.
And their job is really to
project an idea of prestige,
to give the world a picture
of the most respectable, most
high-minded, most artistic and
scientific face of Hollywood.
And their ideas about
what constitutes
prestige are, I think,
very narrow and very kind
of out-of-date and out-of-touch.
And it's not just
a matter of race,
although it has a lot to do with
the current racial controversy,
which is that things
that have too much to do
with popular culture
or that stray
from that kind of narrow idea of
respectability and seriousness
are invisible to the Academy.
So for example, comedies
are a great example.
In the last 15 years there
have been amazing comedies.
Some of the most inventive work
in movies have been comedies.
But you're not going
to see, for example,
Melissa McCarthy getting an
Oscar nomination for Best
Actress in "Spy."
It's kind of just unthinkable.
But that's a great performance.
I'm sorry, that's an
amazing performance.
And similarly,
while the Academy is
open to movies about
the black experience
or with African-American
characters,
those movies have to
be kind of sanctified
by suffering or by
a kind of nobility
or by being about
social problems.
They have to satisfy kind of an
old-fashioned Hollywood liberal
guess-who's-coming-to-dinner
idea about racial progress.
So a movie about Ray
Charles will win Oscars.
A movie about NWA will
not get nominated.
A movie like "Creed"-- I think
a remarkable piece of film with
a terrific lead performance in
it in a way will be invisible
to the Academy, because in
addition to being a terrific
boxing movie, it's a very
low-key and observant
and sensitive look just at the
realities of African-American
life in America.
But that's not
about drug dealers.
It's not about-- I mean, it's
just a very straightforward
movie about the humanity
of its characters,
which is something that the
Academy kind of can't see.
And I think there's
a bigger problem--
I mean, I could go
on and on about this,
so I'll try to keep it short.
But of course, the bigger
problem is the industry itself.
I mean, the Academy
is one target--
and I think an entirely
legitimate target--
for the protest that's going on.
But of course, the real
target and the real point
of this protest is
the abysmal state
of things in the film
industry itself--
not only on matters of
race but gender, too.
4% of studio and
studio subsidiary
released movies are
directed by women.
And there's a whole system in
place of how the deals get made
and how the pictures get
greenlit that excludes people
of color, excludes
women, excludes
all different kinds of stories
and different kinds of talent.
And right now, television
is doing much better.
One of the reasons
also that television
seems so much more
creatively vibrant
sometimes than
movies is because it
is more open to these stories
and to these storytellers.
So this is-- I can't
say it's the beginning,
but this is a stage
in a much longer
and I think more difficult
process that will have to--
and I think will-- depend
on some real change
in the executive suites and
in the mindset of the industry
itself-- which is,
compared to a lot
of other high-profile
industries in this country,
shockingly un-diverse,
shockingly behind the times,
shockingly retrograde
in the ways
that it allows unspoken
prejudices and habits
of discrimination to continue.
So that's the short answer.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
if you could speak
a little bit about your
process, the physical process
of how you watch
these movies and also
your mental process of since
your criticism is so public,
does that change your
mindset versus just watching
a movie for pleasure
with your family?
AO SCOTT: I mean, the process
is that a list of movies
comes out of coming
releases like three or four
weeks ahead of time.
I mean, it changes.
It's always a
little bit volatile.
Things drop of the
schedule, or there are
late things that pop onto it.
My co-chief critic
and I, Manohla Dargis,
take turns picking
our-- this, by the way,
is as an answer to the question
that I'm asked most often.
In fact, almost every time
I've ever given a talk,
people want to know, how do you
decide who reviews what movie?
So I'm answering that
question now, even though.
No one has asked it yet.
So we take turns kind
of cherry-picking what
looks most interesting
to us, and also making
sure that there's
some balance as
far as the works
of major directors.
So if I did "Inside Llewyn
Davis," she did "Hail Caesar,"
or I'll do the
next Coen brothers,
and making sure that at
very busy times of year
the big movies are more
or less equally divided
and that one of us
isn't dominating
the front of the section or
the top of the home page.
And then we assign the rest
out to other staff critics
and to freelancers.
So the movie screen,
I always watch
them projected on a screen
in a screening room,
never-- at least once.
I mean, there are
sometimes movies
that I will have seen
much earlier at festivals
or because there
were early screenings
that if I go back
and watch them again,
I'll watch them off a
DVD or off the link.
But every time, at
least once unless it's
completely impossible,
unless it's
such a small release that they
can't book the screening room.
So I'll see it.
And I'll try to
see it, in a way,
as cold as I can, because
of what you were saying,
to have as few
preconceptions as I can.
I mean, obviously that's
not really possible.
And as I go along and see
more and more and more movies,
I will have opinions
already about work,
previous films by the director
or about the actors and so on.
But even still, I
try to sort of walk
into the theater
having read as little
as I possibly can get away
with reading and having
tuned out whatever my colleagues
have been saying so I can sit
down and have the experience.
And often I only
see it once, so I
have to pay extra close
attention and take notes.
And then I kind of leave
and try to figure out,
what else do I have to do?
It's not always the
same every time,
but sometimes-- this
was based on a book.
Well, I think I'd
like to read the book.
Most of the time I
Are there other movies like
this one that I've missed?
Are there earlier
films by this director
that I should catch up with?
So just whatever it is-- if it's
is a movie about a real person
or an episode in history, do
I need to do some research
to find out about that?
And I'll do that.
And that's partly
just also a way
of procrastinating and
feeling like I'm working
and putting off writing.
It's like, I'd better check that
Wikipedia entry one more time.
And then I kind of--
the writing process
is fairly concentrated
and intensive.
I mean, as everyone who works
for a daily newspaper does,
I've learned how,
when necessary,
to write very quickly.
Sometimes the deadline
is on Wednesday.
The screening is Tuesday night.
I have to get up in the
morning and drink my coffee
and produce the copy in
90 minutes or something.
And I can do that.
That's not my favorite,
but you learn to do that.
And I sort of sit
down, and I figure out
what I'm going to say.
And I always have to
have the lead first.
I can't start writing until I
know how it's going to begin.
And I do write in
a fairly linear way
and then sometimes go back
and move things around.
But it does somehow
have to go in sequence.
I have to see the
argument and see
how I'm going to get
where I'm going to start
and how I'm going
to get to the end
and have a chance, in a way, to
surprise myself along the way.
And I guess to the
other question,
the difference
between-- it's not
really a different experience
of going to the movies.
I mean, I think I
always had the kind
of critic part of my
brain going long before I
was a critic professionally.
It's just kind of
part of what I liked
about going to the
movies, that sort
of thinking and reflecting--
but not to have the obligation
to write about is a great
freedom, because that's
what's really hard.
Thinking is fun.
Writing is hard.
And it was fun to go with
my wife to see "The Martian"
and enjoy "The
Martian" and not have
to think about how to put it
in writing, in 1,200 words
without spoiling anything,
what I thought of it.
AUDIENCE: So there's this
thing that Roger Ebert
said once that has stuck with
me when it comes to criticism.
And it was something like, your
intellect may get confused,
but your emotions will
never lead you astray.
And you've alluded
to this distance
between that first
initial emotional reaction
that you get maybe coming
straight out of the movie
theater, and later trying to
figure out thinking about it
and figuring out how maybe
why do I have that reaction,
intellectualizing it a bit.
And so my question is, how do
you balance those two things?
Because on the one
extreme, you have just
clicking the Like button sort
of purely emotional reaction,
and then on the
other hand you have
that-- if you
intellectualize too much,
you run the risk of
getting really abstract
and people don't understand
what you're trying to say.
AO SCOTT: And I think you
also do risk betraying
something of your own feeling.
I mean, I disagree a little
with what Roger said there,
because I think that your
emotions can lead you astray
and that movies are
such an emotionally
powerful and
sometimes emotionally
overpowering experience.
They can manipulate you.
They can induce
strong feelings in you
that they might not
deserve or they may not
be doing for good reason.
So I mean, there are plenty of
movies-- or not just movies.
I mean, there are
television commercials
that can make you kind of
choke up and feel sentimental.
And there are
techniques for evoking
all kinds of things that
will make you feel that way.
So you shouldn't always
necessarily trust that.
I mean, you should
approach that perhaps
with a little bit of skepticism.
But you can't at the same
time let go of it entirely.
I mean, I do think that
feeling is very important
and that it's the thing, in a
way, that you're the most sure
of-- which doesn't mean that
you always go with it 100%,
but the information
that you have
about a given movie
that you absolutely know
is how it made you feel.
You weren't there when
it was being made.
I mean, movies are very
hard to decode in a way.
You can certainly
understand the techniques
and break them down and think
about the shots and the cuts
and the music and
the performances.
You can analyze them.
You can find out what
kind of lenses were used
and how many takes that scene
took, but you don't necessarily
know any of that, and you might
never get to the bottom of what
was actually
happening, or certainly
what the intentions of
the people involved were.
And usually the
immediate intentions
were to finish the damn thing.
So what you know-- a thing
that Gene Siskel used
to say a lot-- the question
is, what do you know for sure?
What do you know for sure?
And you ask yourself
about a movie,
and what you know
for sure is how
it made you feel-- which, again,
doesn't mean that it's just
the expression of that feeling
is enough to make it criticism.
I guess this is where the
thought and the intellect
and the more cerebral
part of it comes in.
Just saying "I felt
something" isn't criticism,
because it's not necessarily
useful to anybody else.
You just say, I liked that.
I cried.
That sucked.
That was hilarious.
You're not doing any work with
it, and you're not, in a way,
giving anyone else
anything to think about.
So it's somehow the
conversion of that experience
and of those emotions
into something
that is transitive,
that's part of a discourse
that you can talk
about that I think
is what criticism is good for.
AUDIENCE: It's a
sort of similar lines
that we've been talking
to-- when you think
about the artist's
intent or the filmmaker's
intent versus the
work itself, how much
do you consider the intent of
the filmmakers in your reaction
to it?
Does it matter?
Does it not matter?
AO SCOTT: I think it matters.
I mean, I do sort of think that
what Oscar Wilde or his guy is
saying is sort of true, that
sometimes you're putting stuff
in there that the artist didn't.
But you can't necessarily
know the artist's intentions.
And you actually
can't always even ask.
Sometimes it can
be very frustrating
if you're doing an
interview with a filmmaker
and you say, well,
what were you doing?
What were you trying to say?
And they'll say,
well, I was hoping
that we had enough light
for me to get the shot,
or I was thinking
that I was just
so impatient with the actor who
had flubbed the line 50 times.
But I think you do
want to figure out,
in a broader sense, what
is this trying to do?
I think you shouldn't
judge things
according to just completely
arbitrary or irrelevant
standards.
You have to figure out,
well, what is this movie?
What's it trying to do?
What's it trying to say?
What are its intentions,
and how well does it
succeed in fulfilling those?
That's a step in criticism.
I don't think that's
the whole thing.
I think there are
other terms that things
deserve to be judged in.
But they need to be understood
at least in their own terms.
I think that thinking about
just the work itself and kind
of what it is apart from those
intentions is very important,
and I think it's also
important to think--
and where I kind
of often finally
end up when people ask, well,
what side do you see yourself?
Do I see myself as
kind of interpreting
the work of artists or in a
kind of alliance or sympathy
with artists, or
with the audience?
I think of myself as on
the side of the audience.
I'm talking finally
to the people
who are going to consume this,
who are going to see this, who
are going to think about it.
And that's who I am, too.
And to the extent
that I can think
about what the artist might be
doing, that could be useful.
But that's not the main thing.
And in a way, it goes back
to the earlier question
and my earlier answer to
it, what do I know for sure?
What can I speak on with some
authority and some confidence?
It's not what the artist
was thinking in the end,
because I don't know.
It's what I saw, what I thought
I saw, and how I felt about it.
MALE SPEAKER: Who do you
want to win Best Picture?
AO SCOTT: Who do I want
to win Best Picture?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
not who will win.
AO SCOTT: Not who will win.
Who do I want?
Oh, "Mad Max-- Fury Road."
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: That's
the one I haven't seen.
AO SCOTT: All right,
well you should.
It's good.
Well, thank you all.
This was a lot of fun.
[APPLAUSE]